Martha used magic like that to try to make it go astray. Oh yeah.
Come
to
think of it, I did something similar
to Catalina from
the game Boom.  The younger one tries to harm Maria with fire magic
Where Keith uses magic to create a petite private business to help Mario
It's supposed to be, but it
feels a little unfamiliar
[Music]
What's the
matter?  It might be ruined, so
don't say it's okay to follow the demand for love in front of Zumori, but please don't worry about it.
I have to do it At times like
this, it's time to talk about love with girls talk
4 me
Who does Maria like?
Thank you, I'm very happy, but what I want to listen to right now is that kind of thing I like
.  It
's only a matter of time before I fall in love with Maria-chan
Let's do our best from today